وكانت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده لندن توماس جرين فيلد قالت ان
كوريا الشماليه انتهكت عددا كبيرا من
قرارات مجلس الامن الدولي باطلاقها غير
القانوني 69 صاروخا باليستيا خلال العام
الماضي
من امكانيه استعداد كوريا الشماليه لاجراء
تجربه النوويه السابعه منتقده دور الصين
وروسيا في الحمايه الدبلوماسيه ليبيا
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه بشكل غير مسبوق 69
صاروخا باليستيا انتهى كم جميعها العديد
من قرارات من مجلس الامن واكد كوريا
الشماليه عازمها على انتاج السياحه
النوويه تكتيكيه بكميات كبيره من اجل
زياده الترساناتها النوويه بشكل كبير هذا
العمل اثار الكثيرون القلق الحقيقي من ان
كوريا الشماليه مستعده لاجراء تجربه
النوويه سابعه كوريا الشماليه تتجاهل
بوضوح وبشكل صارخ قد الالتزامات الدوليه
من استفزازات كوريا الشماليه ضد اليابان
نحن ايضا قلقون للغايه من استفزازات كوريا
الشماليه تجاه الياباني وجيرانها كما يدين
الحرب الوحشيه وغير المبرره التي اختارتها
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
محمد البقالي محمد مرحبا بك معنا ونستطلع
معك اذا الخيارات الكوريه الجنوبيه بعد
خيبه الامل هذه
محمد خيبه الامل هذه المتوقعه ومتكرره
بالنظر الى موازين القوى في مجلس الامن
الدوليه التي لا تسمح في الوقت الراهن
باصدار يدين او بعقوبات ضد كوريا الشماليه
كوريا الشماليه رغم انها من وجهه نظر مجلس
الامن الدولي قد خلقت كثيرا من قراراته
عندما قامت بتجاربه جديده لصواريخها
الباريسيه بينها تستند الى دعم ثابت لا
يتزحزح لكل من روسيا والصين وهما عدواني
دائما في مجلس الامن الدولي يتم التعاني
بحق النقد الفيتو اي انه لا يمكن لقرار ان
يمضيه مجلس الامن الدولي دون موافقتهما
كوريا الشماليات تعولوا على هذا الدعم
الثابت وبالتالي فلم يكون متوقعا من قرار
مجلس من مجلس الامن الدولي الا مثل هذا
القرار صحيح صحيح صدق هذه مجلس الامن
الدولي ان اداني كوريا الشماليه واصدرها
عقوبات ضدها سته مرات او ست مرات منذ عام
2006 ولكن السياق يبدو مختلف هذه الم
بماذا اساسا الى سياقات من جهه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ثم التوتر الامريكي
الصيني وهو ما يجعل كوريا الشماليه يمكنها
ان تعود بشكل جدي واكثر من اي وقت مضى على
كل من روسيا والصين في مواجهه المعسكر
الاخر الذي يسمى بالمعسكر الغربي الذي
تقوده الولايات المتحده والذي يضم كلا من
بالاضافه الى واشنطن كلا من سيول وبيو همم
طوكيو الولايات المتحده كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان يمكن ان نقول ان هناك عوده الى
ما يمكن وصفه اجواء الحرب البارده بين
هذين المعسرين كوريا الجنوبيه الان يمكن
ان نقول ان هذا الكلام المتعلق بخيبه
الامل واغير ذلك من مجلس الامن الدولي هو
من اجل
الاستهلاك الاعلامي والا اي لم تكن تعول
اصلا على مجلس الامن الدولي هي بدات
بالفعل الان تبحث عن صيغ تحميها اكثر في
مواجهه جارتها كوريا الشماليه يتعلق الامر
اساسا فيما اعلنا من مناورات سات تنظم
الشهر المقبل مع الولايات المتحده ستحاكي
سيناريو وقوع حرب نوويه يتعلق الامر ايضا
باعلان الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي البارحه او
خلال اليومين الماضيين على ان بلده قد
يمضي قدما في اتجاه نشر اسلحه نوويه
تاكتيكيه او امتلاك اسلحه نوويه في حال
وصلت كوريا الشماليه استفزازاتها وبالتالي
يمكن ان نقول الان ان الجميع يعول على
امتلاك السلاح وعلى قوه التحالفات وليس
على مجلسها الامن الدولي هناك الان في
الحقيقه وهنا في سيول الملمس على الاقل
على المستوى السياسي هناك قلق قلق كبير
لماذا لان يتم التعامل مع رئيس كوريا
الشماليه على انه شخص غير هذه اللي توقع
خاصه في السياق الذين شادوا سياق حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وهي التي دفعت الجميع
الى الاعتقاد بان زمن الحروب التي كان
يعتقدوا انه قد ولى او الحروب التي تظهر
بانها مستبعده يمكن في كل لحظه ان تشتغل
محمد البقالي من سولد شكرا جزيلا لك